now a shocking story out of haiti
tonight where president
jovenel moise was assassinated by a
squad of gunman and his wife wounded in
an override
overnight raid at their home now the
killing has sparked unrest chaos
confusion in a country that is already
grappling with
violent crime and poverty and protest
against
authoritarian rule we'll have more
straight ahead but also tonight
iran is raising more concerns after they
now
say they have further enriched their
uranium now state department
spokesperson ned price said it was quote
another unfortunate step backwards well
actually it's more predictable than
unfortunate
this is what a weak foreign policy
begets it emboldens our enemies but
remember
it's this administration they want to go
back to the most insane iranian nuclear
deal
ever and want to go back to the status
quo and not hold the muellers in tehran
accountable for its export of terror as
the world's number one state sponsor of
terrorism
and their refusal to ever negotiate in
good faith you know any place anytime
inspections that would be a pretty good
start meanwhile still
little clarity from team biden amid a
wave of
cyber attacks against u.s cyber
infrastructure
but don't worry biden said quote after
he took his time
ordered his ice cream uh i'm late
because they um
they um they were just briefing me and
um uh i um what am i gonna do about it
let me
they made me write it down let me read
it
i will personally deliver the message to
vladimir putin himself
when asked about his plans to send the
russian leader whatever that means
anyway then look at china tonight
remember russia and china
are providing the iranians weapons to
fight their proxy war in the middle east
that is a dangerous trifecta there but
in china beijing is making more threats
their geographical uh ambitions are on
full display
now they're threatening the united
states they're threatening war
to any u.s action defending taiwan
they're planning on reunification with
taiwan taiwan
and then ask yourself what weight do any
of biden's words carry when they see
his struggles when they see his lack of
mental
acuity alertness awareness and when they
see
his lack of a clear foreign policy
vision here now with reaction louisiana
senator
john kennedy all right so you got cyber
attacks from russia
the iranians enriching again you got
russia and china providing the iranians
arms and china is now saying
yeah we're going for reunification just
like they shut down hong kong it's about
to get worse and if you mess with us
we have 1.5 billion people and we will
take out your military sites
uh what's joe going to do senator
i don't understand president biden's
foreign policy he keeps talking about
rule-based order i don't know what that
means nobody's opposed to rules-based
order that would be like a
opposing golden retrievers but i don't
know what it means
the question he needs to be asking is
what does america want from its foreign
policy
i know what i want i want a foreign
policy that helps create an america in
which people
can continue to prosper and americans
can live their lives as they see fit
and as a moral principle i want that for
every other country
how do you achieve that two rules number
one don't be a bully
and number two don't tolerate bullies
i'm talking about iran and russia and
china
how do you achieve that weakness invites
the wolves uh the reason bullies
uh will fear us is because america is
the strongest
country militarily in all of human
history we're also the wealthiest
country in all of human history
we need to maintain it president biden
is undermining it
he's proposing massive tax increases
which will destroy
wealth he's spent and is proposing to
spend trillions of dollars
that we don't have on things we don't
need
uh num number two um
he's he's proposing to cut the military
we need to be increasing our military
spending
number three six months ago sean we were
on a glide path as a country to energy
independence
president biden stopped that for sure
number four he needs to tell his people
to
stop apologizing for america we have
nothing to apologize for
we're not perfect but we're good when
his u.n
ambassador in her first speech to every
country in the world
and at the u.n in new york says that a
white supremacy is
woven through the fabric of america's
founding principles that's not helpful
you mentioned russia here's what we need
to do with russia
president biden told putin to stop the
cyber attacks
the cyber attacks have continued he
needs to hit
putin with a serious cyber attack two
wrongs don't make a right make it right
but they do make it even
number two he needs to re he meaning
president biden needs to reimpose
sanctions on the nord stream too you
mentioned iran
iran knows what we want no nuclear
warhead
no missile technology and stop exporting
terrorism
president biden needs to give iran six
months we'll continue to talk with them
but no more than six months and if iran
doesn't agree
with additional sanctions sanctions
president biden needs to uh
to hit him so hard that even google
can't find them
um
you have putin gets away a waiver to
build his pipeline while simultaneously
canceling jobs at the keystone xl
pipeline
you have the iranians he lifts the
sanctions
and to be very honest i think it now
becomes
a pivotal question is there a good
chance that
the 1.5 billion dollar bank of china
deal that
zero experience hunter got might have
compromised the biden family with china
and what will joe
do when the reunification with taiwan
comes senator
and my last part is 57 percent of
americans 58 percent of independents a
third of democrats believe
joe's not running the show do you
believe he's running the show
robert cahaly and john states yeah
i i i don't know i just judge the man by
his actions he's
president biden is responsible whether
he's running the show or not
and i can tell you with respect to china
it's also true with iran and russia
weakness invites the wolves if he wants
to get president chi's attention in
china
president biden should do two things
immediately number one
he should negotiate and sign a trade
agreement with taiwan whoa
that will get china's attention and
number two
he needs to publicly back australia
australia has tried to stand up to china
china is boycotting all australian goods
and in australia sends
a lot of its exports to china we need to
come to the real
to the aid of uh of australia
and we need to speak loudly and clearly
and tell the european union we expect
their help
i don't see i agree with much of your
analysis
i don't see it happening there's one
other thing we can do sean last word go
ahead
this is going to be controversial we
need
america needs to vaccinate the world you
don't have to take the vaccine if you
don't want it
but it it's the right thing to do and it
will make friends
all over the world and every vial every
syringe needs to have made
in the usa on it uh
i think for the sake of the world to
give people that option that shows
once again i would argue we showed it
all
throughout our history we abused power
less than any great country
we advance the human condition we share
such invention and innovation
scientifically medically
with other countries for free uh i would
say that makes america
yeah right what american leadership is
all about
senator thank you hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else